first I'll just like to get your
reaction to Aaron TV with Steve Baker
I'm not sure if you caught it but he's
effectively banned the first
Conservative MP to publicly call for
Dominic Cummings to go
is he right
I didn't catch the the interview there
but look I think this comes down to you
know somebody who was trying to do the
best by their four-year-old child who
was in danger of having both parents ill
and so tried to position himself where
there was some family support from a
younger members of that family who could
drop off food and the like and you know
perfectly legitimate questions to ask
about these things very straightforward
answers of being forthcoming and you
know obviously I'd much rather speak to
you about all the things we're doing in
transport to build this country back
after coronavirus which is what I was
hoping to talk to you about this morning
yes somewhat derails I use and last a
couple of days that and the point that
Steve Baker was making on the child is
that in many of his constituents many
parents around the country been
grappling with exactly these concerns of
what to do with child care how to look
after their families when they fall ill
and that it will really stick in the
throat to see what many people would
have seemed to be one rule for that and
then one rule for the elite I think the
most important thing about the guidance
is it says if you are ill you know make
sure you self isolate you stay in that
location and the guidance also says you
know you you have to know to paraphrase
you have to look for common-sense
practical solutions particularly it
refers to when you're looking after
children and I mean just quite perfectly
just more questions to ask him Dominic
coming this is very much in the in the
public eye you know but his his child
and wife much less so and the child not
at all of course and you know they've
what they've done is gone to make sure
that there's a support network around
them obviously both parents were
concerned about being ill I think the
wife was already ill and so they've gone
somewhere which was adjacent to but not
with his parents where both his sister
and I believe in nice as well we're able
to bring food
take that to the door and that sort of
thing meaning that the the you know if
they were both feel that the child was
at least getting some support so I think
they took perfectly sensible rational
steps to try and make sure as anybody
would do as a parent that they could
look after their child and that's
basically the longer than the short of
this story okay so I'm keen to ask you
to some very straightforward factual
questions just to work out exactly what
has happened
so when exactly did Dominic Cummings
first show symptoms of coronavirus and
and what date did he make that journey
from London to Durham yeah I don't want
to disappoint you obviously I'm
transport secretary some experts in
everything to do with building our
infrastructure that particular in the
post corona world I don't know how all
that all the times and dates for you but
I understand that he will have traveled
up there towards the end of March and
stay there remain there for 14 days
didn't leave the property in isolation
as per the rules and the guidance okay
so that journey is 260 miles from London
to Durham that's four and a half hours
in the car with a small child and a sick
wife did they stop at any point
yo your appreciate I wasn't with them so
I can't tell you exactly what what the
journey itself was like but I do know
that they the Dominic Cummings that I
saw I sort of clipped yesterday of him
asking journalists to make sure they
were spaced two metres apart so I know
he's a stickler for those rules about
you know what to do to make sure you're
following the the 2 meter rule and the
likes I'm sure they took all the
necessary precautions but I'm afraid I
don't have the detail of I didn't sort
of track and got the details of tracking
of that journey copy a little bit of
being slightly disappointed that you
don't have the detail because then we
did flag these questions to you before
you came on the show a really unusual
step for us something that you know
we've never really done before but we
acknowledge that you are a transport
secretary we put the questions out there
on social media in the hope that you
would might be had to find out the
answers to them these are really
important questions very simple factual
questions and you're now coming on the
programmes thing you don't know why not
well yeah you me appreciate so if you
came on program actually booked
originally to talk about the transport
announcements I've absolute you know
perfectly legitimate to ask you know a
whole range of questions and questions
have been asked about mr. Cummings
having said that he's put out a
statement downing streets put out a
statement and they've been clear that he
followed the guidance that he did what
we're all supposed to do if you were ill
during this period that particular
period lockdown remain in the same place
don't interact with other people he did
all of those things looked after his
young child I'm afraid I don't have
details you know what time of day and
how many stops sorry I didn't hear he
didn't stay in the same place the
household space to stay in the same
place of you how Crona virus his wife
for showing symptoms of corona virus at
the time and he didn't stay in the same
place
well the I mean he did once once they
you know we were locked down they sort
of hunkered down and they stayed there
for 14 days and yes well everyone has
sort of if you're going to lockdown you
go to the place you're gonna you're
gonna stay and as I say the guidance is
clear that particularly where young
children are involved it says they
actually refers to children specifically
and it says yeah this isn't a sort of
perfect science essentially the guidance
says you'll take you'll want to take the
steps which are practical to be able to
look after your your children or child
in this particular case which in their
case meant having you know a sister or
niece who could drop off food and that's
what they didn't they then remained in
that space and I think there were more
stories today I was saying about you
know has he travel backwards and
forwards accusations that he then went
back up to Dharam again further times
and completely untrue when he came back
to London which was on the 14th of April
I see he's remained in London since and
hasn't been back to Darren said you know
that there's a lots of things being said
here which is completely untrue actually
the basic story is is is actually pretty
straightforward you know a husband and
wife are real they they hunker down they
look after their four-year-old and they
don't move until they're better and
coming back down to
and afterwards would have been traveling
for essential work which was always
allowed to do as well okay so just to be
crystal clear because this is important
you're effectively saying that the two
new allegations the first that mr.
Cummings traveled back up to Durham on
the 19th of April and the second is that
he was seen by a witness apparently in
barniz Castle 30 miles from Durham on
the 12th of April you're going on the
record to say that both of those
allegations are not true
I certainly know that the first one that
you mentioned of traveling back up I
know that's not true
it's put out a statement saying actually
happen a castle a London on the 14th I'm
afraid I don't I don't know but if that
date was true that would have been
outside of the 14-day lockdown period
but I'm afraid I don't have information
on that but I do know that it's not the
case that he's traveled back with some
forwards which seem to be a major part
of the stories I saw in the in the paper
today
have you asked number 10 the answers to
these questions or did they just not
tell you well number 10 put out a
statement on mr. Cummings have put out a
statement with number 10 answering you
know a whole variety of points and it
seems have been a little not feeding
this story for example well I was going
to say for example there was a
suggestion that the police have been
involved and you know that was in I
think the original story but I
understand actually some confusion over
that the police were actually advising
about some security masses so you know
this is all very interesting and you're
absolutely right to ask the questions as
I say I'm sure there's a level of
interest about it but actually probably
how we build ourselves out of
coronavirus big announcements like the
billion pounds programme I announced
yesterday to build the a 66 all the way
into a dual carriageway from Penrith to
Scotch corner things which actually
matters to people's everyday lives or
will do as we come out of coronavirus
obviously things that I'm an expert in
and I can talk to you about and had
hoped to get a bit of time to discuss
today I can sure I'm sure it's very
disappointing to not be able to talk
about the a 66 especially she liked her
on the prayer
mr. shops and but just to pick you up on
what you just said about the police
because I does feel like there is some
confusion here because yesterday's press
conference you said nobody from the
police and spoken to Dominic Cummings
remember of his family but since then
Durham Constabulary said on Tuesday
March the 31st our officers were made
aware that Dominic Cummings had traveled
from London to Durham an officer made
contact the following morning by
telephone during that conversation
mr. Cummings has father confirmed that
his son had traveled with his family
from London to the northeast so who is
being dishonest you or Durham police so
so I think I was saying yesterday about
this specific issue I think in fact it
was mr. Cummings father who contacted
the police not the other way round and
actually it was in references security
advice which you'll appreciate the
family don't want to go into not about
this specific issue okay and so when did
the Prime Minister find out that mr.
Cummings had travelled to Durham as your
viewers will probably remember the Prime
Minister's doing exactly the same period
was pretty ill and in fact eventually in
hospital and in ICU so I don't think
this will have been high on the Prime
Minister's agenda is he I just want to
come back there because we believe that
Dominic Cummings travel to Durham on the
28th to the 29th of March when we were
told that the Prime Minister although
we're showing symptoms of coronavirus
and was self isolating that he was still
lived in the government and that he was
working from number 10 so where we
mislead about how serious the Prime
Minister's in illness was at that time
sorry I'm not quite clear what you mean
by that connection we know the Prime
Minister was unwell we know he carried
on working that's absolutely true and
then he went into hospital very
well-documented I think everyone knew
what was going on there and then of
course ended up in intensive care after
that sorry the point of my question is
that I absolutely accept that the Prime
Minister came very ill but at the time
that we believe that Dominic Cummings
made this journey to Durham we were told
that the Prime Minister was still
working as usual oh yes oh yeah I mean
he was
so why didn't he know about it and or
did he know about it you have to forgive
me Sophie I I don't actually know you
know whether the Prime Minister tracks
every single move of Dominic Cummings I
think he knew that Dominic Cummings was
ill and was self isolating which it was
exactly what he was doing with his wife
and and his child okay and another
question that we did flag to you in
advance now the reason I'm asking these
questions is because you know people
around the country been following the
lock down to the letter and many of them
in really difficult situations making
incredibly difficult sacrifices for
themselves and for their families I mean
just to give one example there many more
it's mal Mohammed Odawa have died
without his family his bedside on the
30th of March now his parents and
siblings couldn't even attend his
funeral was 13 years old and while that
was happening a man centrally involved
in drawing up the recommendations all
the rules for what people should be
doing was traveling to see his family
how is that right I mean I suspect
nearly everyone watching those people
who have been affected and people have
died from coronavirus I can think of
nine or ten people that I know directly
or indirectly and you know my heart goes
out to everybody who's been affected by
this virus and it is true that people
haven't been able to attend
you know funerals and families and so on
and so forth but I just want to be
completely clear about what's happened
here this is not Dominic Cummings went
to see his parents he didn't you know he
was in a separate adjacent property this
is somebody who followed the guidelines
by going to sort of lockdown in order to
be in the best place to ensure that
provision was made for a four-year-old
who clearly would not have been able to
look after himself and as the guidance
makes clear you must do in this
situation the thing which will look
after children for their welfare in the
best possible way which is what people
you know would expect and many any
father would mother and father would
want to do exactly that and that's
what's happened in the situation here
what many people will be trying to get
their head around is that one of the
government's great successes has been
getting people to obey the rules at the
lock down and driving down the cases of
this deadly virus as a result but now
mum to the cabinet seem to be saying
that you need to use your own common
sense that the rules are there for
interpretation that they're guidelines
that you should do what's right for your
own family is saving the job of Dominic
Cummings really more important than
getting people to adhere to the lock
down I really want to push back on that
actually safer because the the the
absolute critical part of this is is you
remaining in the same location whilst
you go through the 14 days of isolation
which is which is what happened here
there but it wasn't though they were
travelling around during the period they
were ill they've stayed in the same
place to do that they made sure the
support network was around them but they
they did that and the guidance didn't
say you must only drive a mile to do
that or whatever it you know it's
clearly every family's position will
have been different through this period
but you look as a certain I you know I
don't want to sort of this obviously is
important and perfectly legitimate
questions to ask they've also been
answered I think pretty clearly and
apart from the a66 the bus and tram
services that we spent 286 million
pounds to bring them back to full
service or something else that I've been
announcing this week and all these other
things I think well actually in the end
be much more significant for people
watching your program because what we
need to know is how we're going to deal
with the recovery stage of this
particularly with the 1st of June which
is the earliest possible stage pay
moment to go into phase 2 of this coming
up and shortly all of this is probably
more interesting than how one you know
family looked after their four year old
by staying in a single location and not
has been as suggested and the newspapers
driving back and forth and back and
forth I think it you know there are sort
of big issues here which matter to the
country as a whole
and you know it once it's great to get
into the detail of this I think most
these questions have been answered now
ok thanks for the job tips much
appreciated and now one of the things of
course that many people will legitimate
be very
we're interested in knowing is about
schools and nurseries whether or not
they're actually going to be opening on
June the 1st it's only eight days away
something that affects course millions
of families so will schools and
nurseries some primary school at age
year groups and nurseries be seeking to
have children attending from the 1st of
June yeah that certainly is the plan and
I think it's really important because
you know we're in a position where
children are clearly missing out and
very vital formative parts of their
education and particularly in that sort
of reception year one year six which
absolutely crucial moments in children's
education we've seen this happen in
other countries Denmark and Germany
France now some of the schools are going
back in those cases as we would do here
very cautiously not in large class sizes
taking all of the necessary precautions
and elsewhere where this has been done
the infection rate has been kept and the
same as well so we've seen it work
elsewhere I think there may even be over
20 countries now who've sent some a
limited number of children back and so I
think it is important that we try to do
that from the 1st of June and that's
that's certainly the intention okay
thank you and just finally you really
have drawn the shortest of short straws
this weekend
you signed up to do that daily briefing
yesterday from Downing Street today's
morning TV round hoping to talk about
your transport announcement and then the
Domenic coming story broke and we
attempted to switch off your alarm this
morning miss out speaking to you and
look at you look I appreciate you give
me at least a moment to talk about some
of these transport announcements and our
approach to this which is going to be to
build our way back from coronavirus and
look at yeah this has been a huge moment
for this country and globally we've
never seen anything like it in a hundred
years but how we respond now and how we
build back and how we create the
infrastructure the jobs and the skills
and bring this country back to life
again is going to be absolutely
essential and as you said I had hoped to
be talking about that
all of those things through the press
conference yesterday and and these media
interviews this morning but I appreciate
these give me a a small opportunity to
do that we're bringing back the buses
and the trams and the trains the
important thing is that people avoid the
rush hour don't go and amuse them unless
you absolutely can't walk cycle or drive
because we will only be able to take
about a fifth of the normal passenger
numbers even when we have 100% of the
services back in place